[Musique]
bonjour à tous dimanche en politique
spéciale nous avons installé nos caméras
ce matin à belfort hier ici même
plusieurs milliers de personnes ont
dénoncé le plan social de general
electric qui veut supprimer un millier
d'emplois
un massacre social pour reprendre les
mots d'un syndicaliste du groupe
américain alors la résistance dans la
cité du lion peut-elle suffire comment
faire le poids face à une multinationale
américaine quelle suite donner à cette
mobilisation populaire
on va en débattre avec nos quatre
invités ici sur les bords de la
savoureuse
philippe petitcolin délégué cfe cgc à
general electric vous êtes notamment le
porte-parole de l'intersyndicale du
groupe américain ici à belfort un autre
syndicaliste
et sur ce plateau francis fontana
délégué vous du syndicat sud également à
general electric
marie josé fleury présidente des
vitrines de belfort l'association de
commerçants du centre ville qui s'est
mobilisé également hier et dominique
baldini président de la vallée de
l'énergie une association qui fédère les
différentes entreprises du secteur de
l'énergie dans le territoire bonjour à
tous les quatre merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation alors comme d'habitude
en vous aussi vous pouvez participer à
cette émission y participer sur les
réseaux sociaux avec vos commentaires et
le mot ds dit mme paul fc comme dimanche
en politique franche comté alors
monsieur petit colin il est m la ville a
rassemblé plusieurs milliers de
personnes derrière une seule cause
défendre les emplois de general electric
est ce que cette mobilisation vous a
réconforté vous qui fait partie des
principaux concernés
tout à fait hier c'était un jour
historique pour belfort depuis les
grandes grèves d'alstom la suite à la
fermeture de bulle je pense c'est la
plus grosse mobilisation citoyenne
donc ça nous réconforte ça nous donne de
l'énergie pour continuer le combat car
on voit que au delà des salariés c'est
tous les citoyens de belfort et du nord
franche comté qui sont derrière nous
francis fontana c'est quelle quantité de
manifestants il faut pour être assez
nombreux façade general electric
on va écouter je pense que signé hier il
y avait selon nous ce sont 8000 salariés
selon la police 5000 je pense que avec
un chiffre tel que celui là on a déjà
marqué les esprits c'est au moins deux
fois plus que la grandes mobilisations
d'il ya trois ans pour défendre
alstom qui était menacée de
délocalisation par exemple c'est ça
c'est deux fois plus donc je pense que
ça marquera les esprits vous savez les
américains on nous fait tout pour que
ces mobilisations elles réussissent que
ce soit les mobilisations des salariés
ou celle de la population celle d'hier
c'était une réussite et je pense que ça
marquera les esprits
marie josé fleury c'était une évidence
pour les citoyens les commerçants les
acteurs économiques de participer à ce
mouvement
bien sûr tout à fait pour nous ça a été
dès le départ une évidence je dirais que
ceux de cette annonce de plan social a
été en tout cas un véritable choc
véritable onde de choc parmi le monde
économique
et c'est vrai que tous les commerçants
dès le départ on souhaitait collaborer
avec l'intersyndicale de general
electric pour les soutenir pour être
solidaire de leur action et pour que sur
ce petit département on puisse tous
s'unir pour parler de la même voix et
porter haut et fort la lutte contre ce
plan social qui est tout simplement
inacceptable
dominique val d'huisne et vous êtes chef
d'entreprise les chefs d'entreprise
étaient unies au sahara y est hier c'est
vraiment une spécificité de la
manifestation d'hier ça allait au sein
des syndicats de salariés jusqu'au
syndicats patronaux tout à fait le medef
lui mm
la cie pme et d'autres encore étaient
présents pour comprendre ce mouvement de
masse il faut bien se dire que les sous
traitants travaillent quotidiennement
avec les salariés de general electric
donc forcément en bon franc-comtois il y
à des amitiés qui se sont noués on ne
travaille pas uniquement pendant la
journée on se voit le soir on connaît
des problèmes on connaît des enjeux et
on les a on a vu venir les problèmes
depuis une année et demi maintenant bel
ouvrage est la deuxième ville de franche
comté mais ça reste une petite ville où
tout le monde se connaît tous le monde
connaît
salariés d'alstom ou de jim et bien sur
rue89 même on se connaît plus que ça on
travaille ensemble on a résolu des
problèmes techniques dus voir
scientifique ensemble donc vous pensez
il ya effectivement plus qu'une
solidarité il y à une communion une
espérance commune pour traiter ce
problème
philippe collas petitcollin union des
corps intermédiaires on va dire des
syndicats de salariés des syndicats
patronaux et puis union politique il y
avait le centre névralgique politique du
pays
hier était à belfort il y avait
quasiment tous les partis politiques
représentés et des ténors nationaux
tout à fait on avait vraiment tous les
partis politiques avec la france est
soumise avec monsieur mélenchon avec
nathalie arthaud avec philippe poutou
avec des gens du lr du ps de génération
même des gens d'europe écologie les
verts qui porte aussi notre notre projet
car avec la montée en puissance du
renouvelable
la turbine à gaz est indispensable c'est
important que europe écologie les verts
portent ce projet avec nous vous citez
pas les gens de la majorité
présidentielle pourtant il était là il y
avait plusieurs députés la république en
marche aussi tout à fait il y avait
également des gens de la réplique en
marche
maintenant on attend une réponse de ce
parti en particulier prisons de la
république par rapport à ce problème
nantes va devenir national sait quelle
position il va prendre pour la stratégie
industrielle de notre pays
on voit bien qu'il ya trois ans il ya un
accord qui a été signé qui dit oui vous
pouvez racheter la branche net d'alstom
à condition que vous développez les
emplois que vous développez l'industrie
que vous créez des emplois aujourd'hui
on voit que le contrat n'est pas rompu
le prix dans la république doivent doit
se positionner pour venir sauvegarder
nos emplois et j'ai envie de dire la
cathédrale mondial de l'énergie qui est
belfort on est capable de faire des
petits obinna gaz et une vapeur
l'alternateur c'est le seul site au
monde qui est capable de faire ça il
faut se garder francis fontana la
solution allait clairement politique
elle a deux aspects elle est d'abord
elle est d'abord chez les salariés c'est
vrai que la mobilisation des salariés
c'est le socle pour nous on est
syndicaliste
il faut qu'on en passe par là si on
n'avait pas les salariés derrière nous
on ne serait pas légitime a porté ce
projet avec cette force là et avec cette
conviction
donc nous on est déterminés dans ce qui
concerne l'intersyndicale mais c'est
parce que les salariés sont derrière
nous nous soutiennent on a énormément de
messages de soutien beaucoup de salariés
nous qu'on croise spontanément viennent
vers nous donc ça c'est la base c'est le
socle est derrière effectivement ça nous
permet de mobiliser la population ce
qu'on a vu hier on travaille depuis
assez longtemps avec pardon les
politiques tous les politiques le champ
politique complet et a vu par exemple
cessé le travail quelques jours après la
visite de bruno le maire quand vous avez
estimé que les engagements qu'il avait
pris le ministre de l'économie devant
vous quand il est venu à belfort
n'avaient pas été tenues oui tout à fait
il faut qu'on arrive enfin c'est notre
socle c'est notre base et c'est par ce
moyen là qu'on arrive à peser après
évidemment quand ce combat il et il est
fort à ce niveau là au niveau des
salariés ça se diffuse dans la
population parce que les salariés ils
ont tous une famille ils ont tous des
amis à belfort on l'a dit on chez les
sous traitants et donc ça diffuse cette
cette mobilisation est ensuite donc à
les politiques locaux là sur ce plan là
on était c'était déjà bien engagés on a
vu que les nationaux sont derrière nous
elle rem locale enfin la république en
marche local il était là on a eu peu de
contacts avec eux et pour cause puisque
la position pour l'instant du
gouvernement et du président
et quand même relativement éloignée de
tout ça un petit aparté hier tous les
partis politiques étaient représentés
mais l'intersyndicale a refusé de une
entrevue avec les les élus régionaux du
rassemblement national
on a vu notamment deux élus régionaux
cantonné dans un coin de la mairie qui
avaient pas accès à la salle où tous les
élus étaient pouvez vous nous expliquer
votre votre positionnement par part
alors en deux mots je vais faire très
simple l'intersyndicale avait été
sollicité par le rassemblement national
les élus du rassemblement national pour
la participation à la réunion des partis
politiques et la conférence de presse
qu'on organisait cette organisation
c'est l'intersyndicale qui l'a prise en
charge
c'est nous qui avons déclaré la
manifestation et à ce titre on invite
qui on a envie d'inviter le nous avons
fait savoir par mail vendredi au
rassemblement national de façon très
claire que nous ne partagions pas les
valeurs du rassemblement syndical e
national pardon l'intersyndicale parce
que je voulais cité l'intersyndicale
parce que j'ai vu que le rassemblement
national parlait beaucoup de deux
syndicats simplement alors qu'on est
trois donc l'intersyndicale ne partage
pas les valeurs du rassemblement
national nous leur avons fait savoir à
nous leur avons dit qu'ils n'étaient pas
les bienvenus et donc quand ils se sont
ils ont forcé l'entrée à cette réunion
il souhaitait forcé l'entrée à cette
réunion notre service d'ordre a fait à
jouer son rôle et les orcs foule marie
josé fleury
vous êtes une ancienne élue en plus
d'être aujourd'hui présidente de
l'association des commerçants
la solution elle passe par une
un front commun de l'ensemble des
politiques locaux oui bien évidemment je
crois que monsieur fofana vient avec
justesse de le rappeler il y a déjà une
volonté en tout cas des salariés
eux-mêmes à lutter contre ce plan social
pour sauvegarder l'emploi
et quelque part pour sauvegarder notre
territoire je crois qu'on l'a assez dit
et dans les différentes conférences de
presse je lui ai assez répété leur
emploi ce sont aussi les nôtres bien
évidemment l'avenir de ce territoire
l'avenir de nos familles de nos enfants
parce que je crois que ce territoire est
tellement petit que chaque maille en
tout cas qui le composent est importante
et si l'une de ces miles et sectionné à
la base et bien la chaîne va s'étioler
petit à petit tombé tomber complètement
donc le combat bien évidemment il est
aussi politique puisque je dirais que
les politiques sont les décisionnaires
ils doivent donc faire front commun
encore une fois pour lutter contre ce
plan qui risque de mettre sur le carreau
on va le dire tout notre territoire et
je dirais que ça ne va pas toucher que
l'économique
ça va toucher également tout ce qui est
social culturel immobilier scolaire je
discutais avec certains maires de
petites communes qui me disait que si
jamais des familles partait il y aurait
des fermetures d'écoles
indéniablement donc c'est vraiment la
structuration j'allais dire d'un
territoire aujourd'hui qui est en jeu et
je pense que ce qu'il sait ce qu'il doit
et c'est ce qui préoccupe en tout cas
les politiques aujourd'hui qui avec
l'ensemble du corps des citoyens toutes
tendances toutes catégories
socioprofessionnelles confondues doivent
s'unir pour porter haut et fort le
message de solidarité et de lutte avec
l'intersyndicale de general electric et
dominique
belle unis quelle marge de manoeuvre ont
aujourd'hui les pouvoirs politiques face
à une multinationale comme general
electric
il y a déjà des accords qui n'ont pas
été respectées je crois me souvenir que
belfort devait être le centre
d'excellence pour tel ou tel parti de de
l'énergie je pense que le problème c'est
que nos politiques ne connaissent
peut-être pas assez de monde industriel
il y a pas comme dans d'autres pays des
industriels qui accèdent à des postes de
responsabilité politique et inversement
vous savez les problèmes que l'on vit
aujourd'hui était prévisible depuis
plusieurs années mais il faut être
impliqué il faut connaître les métiers
voilà c'est un problème de stratégie
industrielle c'est ça que vous nous
dites ils ont été bons ils ont trop fait
confiance et general electric peut-être
je ne dirais pas ça je pense qu'ils ont
tous la volonté de bien faire ce que je
rencontre en tout cas on vraiment la
volonté de bien faire mais entre avoir
la volonté de bien faire et à vous voir
dans la tête la stratégie qu'il faut
suivre pour ne pas se tromper ou pour
faire les bons choix c'est autre chose
je pense que des américains sont
beaucoup plus professionnelle que nous
et en particulier quand on voit
l'histoire d'alstom en particulier
l'ancien président qui aurait pu avoir
des problèmes juridiques aux états unis
je crois qu'il faut peut-être s'inspirer
de de savoir faire américain de
l'intelligence comment économique qui
parvient au meilleur niveau de l'état
aux états unis pour ça que je pense
qu'il faudrait que effectivement le
président notre président vienne
discuter avec tous les acteurs
économiques
alors justement philippe petitcolin
faisait commencer par ça aujourd'hui
vous en appelez au président de la
république en personne
que peut faire que souhaitez vous que
fasse emmanuel macron aujourd'hui pour
sauver general electric c'est très
simple
manuel macron il a fait signer un accord
l'esprit de l'accord c'est oui vous
pouvez racheter la branche d'alstom à
condition de développer l'industrie de
développer les filières industrielles
les emplois or aujourd'hui l'accord
n'est pas respecté
donc si l'accord n'est pas respecté sur
les enfants ils ont payé
non c'était soit ancrée soit ancrée
mille emplois soit en paix ils ont
préféré payer ça c'est une des clauses
il ya d'autres clauses dans l'accord en
particulier l'article 3.4 qui dit que
belfort doit rester le centre européen
50 hertz et l'article 3.5 qui dit que
les équipes mondiales de directions du
tas tominaga 50 athlètes logé à belfort
et l'article 3.6 qui dit que cet
engagement et pour une durée de dix ans
donc c'est aspect là de l'accord ne sont
pas respectés et c'est la raison pour
laquelle on a ce plan se tient
actuellement et donc emmanuel macron et
mieux la croûte ou temps lol comme le
prévoit l'accord peut saisir les
tribunaux français pour faire une
injonction ingénieur électrique à faire
respecter l'accord ou si general
electric affirme clairement qu'ils
veulent fermer belfort dans ce cas là
j'ai envie de dire rendez-nous d'alstom
c'est à dire en national c'est une piste
que qui peut être envisagée nationaliste
les investisseurs français peuvent
capitaliser reprendre l'entreprise sont
des choses qu'il faut maintenant
envisager non mais alors soyons clairs
c'est la nationalisation est aujourd'hui
une des préconisations des syndicats de
general electric à belfort aujourd'hui
n'ont pas de position claire sur la
prison de general electric que
vétérinaire électrique est-ce que
générique compte fermer belfort ou
compte garder belfort compte à
introduire des filières d'avenir si
génériques se positionne clairement sur
le fait qu'ils veulent fermer belfort le
gouvernement doit protéger notre
patrimoine industriel qui a de l'avenir
qui peut dire que la filière énergie n'a
pas d'avenir
qui peut dire que l'aviation n'a pas
d'avenir et doit se positionner pour
développer l'industrie à belfort j'ai
envie de dire monsieur macron à une
opportunité unique aujourd'hui soit il
espère générer lectrique qui tue belfort
soit ils se positionnent et transferts
ce carnage il transpire transforme ce
carnage industrielle annoncée par un
avenir industriel radio de belfort car
la fia énergétique a de l'avenir car
l'aviation pesanteur de belfort francis
fontana la perspective l'hypothèse
nationalisation vous la défendent
également pourquoi pas c'est
effectivement c'est une des pistes à
laquelle on réfléchit alors on en n'est
pas tout à fait encore là puisque les
dessins comme l'a dit philippe les
dessins de general electric en tout cas
affiché ne sont pas claires pour nous
ils sont très claires pour la pour
l'activité turbines à gaz les le plan de
800 suppressions d'emplois c'est la
première étape
évidemment derrière ce sera la fermeture
et si cette activité ferme
évidemment cela fragilisera les autres
entités de general electric à belfort
puisque jusqu'à présent on échange avec
monsieur boldini juste avant il y avait
des passerelles entre les différentes
entités
si vous réduisez les possibilités de
passerelle lorsque les activités sont
plus ou moins voilà c'est fluctueront
c'est cyclique
donc il y aura cette difficulté est donc
ceci juste sujet il est majeur pour
l'état il est majeur il faut que le
gouvernement et le président la
république prenne la mesure de tout ça
et il faudra qu'il se positionne à
partir du moment où general electric
n'aura pas ne répondra pas clairement
cette situation quel regard vous portez
sur cette perspective dominique balbigny
je pense qu'on peut pas ne pas envisager
effectivement une aide de l'état pour
pressurer l'avenir des unités de belfort
au niveau mondial et au niveau énergie
moi je suis frappé quand même content
parce que je dis beaucoup la presse je
suis frappé par ce que dit le nouveau
patron d'airbus qui se permet
d'enguirlander tous les sous traitants
aéronautiques de toulouse ont désormais
bon sens vous n'allez pas assez vite
vous êtes trop cher aller chercher des
fournisseurs à l'étranger aller chercher
des fournisseurs étrangers mois dont les
études ont été payés par l'état quand
même moi mes parents étaient ouvriers et
bon j'ai fait de bonnes études parce que
j'étais bon en maths moi je je je
j'aurais honte de de préconiser des
solutions étrangères alors que c'est la
france qui m'a tout donné en quelque
sorte
voilà oui il faut il faut trouver des
solutions comprenez on la voit des
éoliennes c'est bien mais on arrive à
des aberrations
il y à des éoliennes installées en
france qui ont été fabriqués au pays bas
qui sont installés par des ouvriers
polonais et qui sont financés par des
banques australiennes
moi je ne sais pas à temps at-on une
stratégie industrielle
vous savez j'ai fait des études
d'ingénieur et économique s'il y avait
une stratégie industrielle dans ce pays
je pense que je l'aurais comprise
marie josé fleury oui je pense quand
même qu'il faut quand même un moment
donné on puisse dans ce pays tirer les
leçons de la politique
la non politique industrielle on l'a
vécu en tout cas sur belfort nos depuis
les années 90 avec je dirais la vente
d'alstom par appartement si je puis dire
donc comme le dit monsieur baldini c'est
vrai que ce qui arrive aujourd'hui c'est
c'est pas une grande surprise
encore une fois c'était désastre annoncé
et j'espère on a cassé anticipé au
niveau politique vous pensez on ne sait
pas qu'on n'a pas anticipé ici que ça
fait 40 ans je peux dire qu'alain vos
côtés les yeux aux appuis politiques
industrielles depuis 40 ans dans ce pays
enfin je veux dire on a quand même subi
à belfort honeywell bull ensuite il ya
eu alstom aujourd'hui c'est general
electric
je veux dire ce sont quand même des
souffrances à répétition ce sont des
massacres industriels à répétition c'est
la perte complète de nos fleurons
industriels que l'on laisse partir
puisque les conséquences sur l'activité
économique l'activité commerciale
évidemment les écoles t en parliez tout
à l'heure
enfin je veux dire le meilleur exemple
c'est quand même la vente des tgv qui
maintenant doit s'accompagner des
brevets du savoir faire et qui prive
d'emplois ici nos entreprises donc un
moment donné quand même je dirais que
profitons au moins et monsieur
petitcolin a raison je veux dire c'est
quand même l'occasion de prouver
qu'aujourd'hui le gouvernement a la
volonté de dadis réaliser notre pays de
continuer à soutenir l'industrie qui
depuis de nombreuses années est
complètement les siens la bonde où ce
sont les grands groupes en fait qui
décide de la politique industrielle en
france et ça c'est franchement
inacceptable et petit cola nous sommes
vraiment une période charnière bien se
rendre compte que belfort c'est le
champion du monde de l'énergie
vous avez la moitié des 4000 personnes
qui sont les ouvriers qui savent
assemblée des turbines à vapeur et
obinna à gaz alternateur général trick
l'objectif c'est d'y stocker tout ça il
avait l'autre moitié ce sont des
ingénieurs des techniciens qui sont
capables d'installer des centrales
électriques mais un style soviétique
david exactement l'atelier centrale
turbine à gaz et certains le charbon
nucléaire du photovoltaïque du
renouvelable si une compétence clé que
general electric a décidé de délocaliser
en inde en pologne au mexique
est ce que vous disiez tout à l'heure
avec l'éventualité d'une nationalisation
la question c'est ce que general
electric est prêt à vendre aussi alors
et vous me disiez avant l'émission
oui parce que general electric à
l'épreuve de dette tout à fait général
trika des gros prennent dette et ont
déjà vendu beaucoup beaucoup de business
law l'éclairage le transport les les
petits moteurs à gaz délai toute la
partie capitale et c'est tard ils ont un
gros problème de dette
et aujourd'hui il ya deux filières qui
marche très très bien c'est l'aviation
et la santé qui veut le garder et dans
les énergies ils veulent garder le
renouvelable
éventuellement le gaz et tout le reste
ils veulent vendre donc aujourd'hui est
aussi une opportunité peut-être pour les
investisseurs quand je parle de la
sionisation séparément la salaison ce
que je veux dire c'est que général trick
est prêt à vendre
donc l'état où d'autres investisseurs
pourraient se positionner aujourd'hui
sur les métiers qui a à belfort pour
garantir la pérennité du site et parce
que le marché de l'énergie a de l'avenir
et qui a beaucoup d'argent à se faire
sauf que general electric aujourd'hui ne
veut plus investir
la seule stratégie c'est supprimer les
usines licencier les gens délocaliser
l'activité ans dans les pays à bas coûts
et ça va conduire à la destruction du
business on a été plus ou moins épargné
depuis trois ans avec l'accord des
milles mais par contre il ya beaucoup de
personnes qui ont déjà parti et dans les
autres pays
beaucoup de plans de licenciements et
qu'est ce qui s'est passé le business
n'a pas remonté le business s'est
littéralement effondré le plan de
licenciements y faire monter le cours de
bourse mais à long terme
l'avr d'entreprise elle en prend un gros
coup donc aujourd'hui peut-être qu'une
des solutions c'est une reprise de
l'activité pas forcément une
autorisation
parce que general electric est en
situation de pouvoir vendre francis
fontana en attendant une éventuelle
décision politique ou un éventuel
repreneur privé
la stratégie des syndicats aujourd'hui
c'est gagner du temps on a vu que vous
avez empêché par deux fois la tenue de
réunions qui devaient lancer le plan
social que vous attaquez le plan social
en justice
oui gagner du temps là alors on ne sait
pas gagner du temps pour gagner du temps
ça laisse le temps de se retourner
peut-être et de l'avantagé de collection
évidemment on aime on l'a expliqué à
monsieur le maire quand il est venu la
question de la temporalité temporalité
pendant lé crucial dans cette affaire
parce que évidemment la question de la
diversification qui part qui permettrait
de développer des activités nouvelles
sur belfort et qui permettrait de
compenser comment je le disais tout à
l'heure les éventuels cycle bas de
marché dans telle ou telle entité ne
vont pas se mettre en place tout de
suite et donc avec les ordonnances j'ai
rappelé hier aux politiques en mairie
pour leur dire qu'il fallait qu'ils
travaillent sur ces questions là qui
retrait cote le code du travail avec les
ordonnances d'abord enfin la loi
rebsamen puis les ordonnances et le
comprime à caen etc
les ordonnances travail le délai pour un
peu un pse de ces temples au plan de
sauvegarde de l'emploi ce qu'ont à quoi
le plan social auparavant voilà plan
plan de sauvegarde de l'emploi
ces quatre mois et en quatre mois déjà
pour étudier toutes les pistes possibles
c'est forcément impossible puisque la
direction n'a pas fait le travail devant
nous ça fait plus d'un an qu'on est sur
ces sujets et quand bien même ça se
mettrait en place les licenciements
seraient faits avant dans un délai très
court avant tout ces filières se met en
place et donc les compétences et les
savoir-faire serait éparpillés dans la
nature et donc c'est pas c'est pas
cohérent comme projet c'est pour ça
qu'on demande du temps qu'on veut
absolument repoussé ce au moins dans un
premier temps stopper ce ps pour
travailler sérieusement avec le
gouvernement les équipes du ministère
avec general electric et puisque
aujourd'hui son corruption business et
qu' on puisse monter des projets qui
tiennent la route et qui favorise un qui
développe l'industrie comme ce com comme
c'était prévu dans l'accord de 2014
dominique bayle du nid j'imagine que
l'ensemble des entreprises du secteur de
l'énergie
ici réfléchissent déjà certains ont
anticipé ces pistes de diversification
vous avez tout à fait raison j'ai
rencontré vendredi
donc monsieur mogis et monsieur martin
de la commisson maugis ce qu'on appelle
monsieur 50 millions j'ai été frappé par
par leur connaissance du poids
d'internet gérer si c'est la commission
qui gère les 50 millions câblier general
electric en compensation des emplois non
créer une commission au niveau national
qui va gérer cet argent dont le
gouvernement a promis qu'elle serait en
grande partie investie à belfort
normalement voilà donc cesser monsieur
mogis monsieur martin sur les grands
connaisseurs de du monde international
je pense qu'il est qu'il est important
en tout cas c'est le message que j'ai
fait passer
il est important que l'on fasse appel à
des adresses pas si on peut appeler ça
des cabinets de consultants où on peut
aussi faire appel au réseau d'ambassades
en france puisque la france un fort
réseau d'ambassades au niveau mondial il
faut tout de suite mais tout de suite
faut pas attendre voilà faire appel à
toutes les industries qui pourrait être
ou services qui pourrait être intéressé
par les compétences de belfort ça c'est
une première chose ensuite effectivement
les sous traitants qui connaissent des
problèmes depuis 20 ans on va dire fin
ont engagé à travers la vallée l'énergie
et avec l'aide de la région des actions
de diversification pour l'instant on a
fait un état des lieux avec d'ailleurs
les compétences de general electric
oui il faut il faut agir et vite aussi
pour soutenir leur trésorerie parce que
les commandes ont baissé elles vont
encore baisser
et là je pense qu'il ya encore des
transferts en hongrie ou dans d'autres
pays un accord on en revient toujours à
râler il faut agir vite très rapidement
philippe petitcolin parce qu'il est il
est bientôt midi la suite pour
l'intersyndicale pour les salariés c'est
quoi vous êtes convoqué mercredi par
votre direction c'est ça tout à fait on
est convoqué mercredi à paris parce que
comme aucune percée on n'arrive pas il
vole pas il n'arrive pas à faire des
réunions à belfort pour les bonnes
raisons donc il faut qu'on se pose la
question de toute façon il faudra y à
paris pour faire voter le mandat pour
agir en justice jeudi à 14 heures au
tribunal d'instance pour faire suspendre
le plan car sécurité et on suivra ça
évidemment sur france 3 franche comté
merci à tous les quatre s'est passé très
vite merci d'être venu ici à belfort sur
les bords de la savoureuse pour cette
émission dimension politique prend des
vacances vos programmes d'été à partir
de la semaine prochaine et puis on se
retrouve pour de nouveaux débats
politiques à la rentrée profitez bien de
votre après midi à bientôt
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]